[Music]
well thank you all for coming i hope
this
will be interesting so
this course is obviously intended as an
antidote to the very famous book chance
and necessity by jacques mano which i'm
sure many of you will have read
he was a nobel prize-winning molecular
biologist
but in this book as one can tell by the
title he treats
these as the only two causal categories
in the universe
are the things that chance or their
necessity this is a big mistake
because there's a huge amount of
evidence of purpose everywhere and i
just look around you this year
computer the screens there is evidence
of purpose
all around us in the universe and so he
was missing out
one of the major causal categories that
clearly
is causally effective in the real
universe in which we live
and so we need a bigger causal framework
than he was using to make sense of
things now
i'm not going to claim to solve the hard
problem of consciousness and i'm not
going to solve
the problem of free will but i will
provide a framework
in which the latter problem looks a lot
better than
if you don't adopt this kind of
framework and i hope that'll become
clear
so this session randomness in the
universe things are not determinate and
the take-home message
is that randomness occurs in the
universe
physics does not determine a unique
outcome from initial conditions now i
hasten to say some of my physics
colleagues do not
agree with this and people like my
friend martin reese who's
the recent president of the royal
society
believes that if we had sufficient
computing power and if we could
gather enough data at the start of the
universe
we would know everything that happens in
the universe at future times from that
initial data this goes back to la plus
the idea that the universe is
deterministic why because at the basis
the physics of the universe is what the
physicists call hamiltonian dynamics it
is a determinate physical system
the initial data given the physics
dynamics determines the outcome
it's very strange that people should
hold to this because it's over a hundred
years since we've known about quantum
mechanics
and we've known that the universe is not
determinate so it's kind of paradoxical
that people should still be holding on
to that not only that
but at least 50 years ago the idea of
chaos
and indeterminism even in
hamiltonian systems was also understood
now the references for this section of
the course
quantum randomness any text on basic
quantum physics so for instance richard
feynman's book six
easy pieces chapter six talks about
quantum and discernmency or
a much more recent book general
milburne's book schroedinger's machines
the quantum technology that is reshaping
everyday life chapter one talks about it
and then the other thing i'm going to
concentrate on is microbiological
randomness and there's a wonderful book
on this by peter hoffman
called life's ratchet how molecular
machines
extract order from chaos and
there's a as we will be developing this
firstly at the
foundational levels quantum physics says
the the
game the idea of determinism
won't start for foundational reasons
it's not true
in the real universe in which we
actually live the question is what about
randomness in biology now digital
computers i'll talk about this are
totally deterministic and this carries a
heavy heavy price if you are programming
a digital computer
those of you who've engaged in program
will know if you just get one stop for a
full stop wrong and put a comma in this
place
the whole thing comes to a grinding hot
an error message comes up the
screen and it doesn't work and so
the way that digital computers work with
programs that are totally deterministic
is not a very good way for biology to
work and biology does not
work in that way there's a huge amount
of randomness
at the bottom levels of biology and
biology has
understood this it is developed in order
to
live in this environment and to take
advantage of it so biology just
doesn't just treat randomness as an
enemy that has to be controlled biology
uses randomly at the micro levels as a
tool
in creating what the biology wants and
that's what this book is about
life's ratchet how molecular machines
extract order from chaos
now where do complex systems come from
the emergence of complexity is
unpredictable from the initial data in
the universe and i'll make this explicit
as we're going so i'm going to talk
about unpredictable emergence
of complexity at the universe and the
foundational reason is that quantum
physics
is unpredictable and vienna heisenberg
and
feynman and all the others say that
at the foundations the true nature of
physics
is that it is not deterministic
and it's not a question that we don't
have enough data if we could find
enough data we would be able to predict
quantum physics
says it's not that there are hidden
variables missing
variables quantum physics says by the
very foundational nature of quantum
physics
what happens in the universe the
microscopic scales
cannot be described in a deterministic
way and many of you probably know that
but i want to emphasize
it because it's absolutely key now the
absolute foundational
experiment in quantum physics is the
two-slit experiment you've got a source
on the left a first screen which has a
source in it and it can be either
particles
that then goes the waves spread out
to a second screen where there are two
slits and they have to be
an appropriate distance part they have
to be very very small for you to see
this
and from those two slits waves spread
out and they hit then
the final screen the question which
quantum physics was trying to discover
way back a hundred years ago is light
wave or particles
and if life was waved you get bars of
light
sections where interference takes place
constructively
namely there's a series of waves from
the two slits and they either add up
or they destroy each other where they
add up you get a bar of light
where they destroy you get a bar of dark
and that is constructive
and destructive interference showing
that light
is a wave but under the right
circumstances light is a particle and if
you have
particles going through those two slits
you get
those light and dark things but you get
it building up
in a particulate manner but light is
actually also from the quantum viewpoint
photons its particles and the trick and
the thing is to get the source of light
to reduce the intensity of the lord
further and further
so that instead of millions of photons
coming through any second you reduce it
until you're emitting one photon
at a time and when you do that that
photon goes through the double slit
and it ends up somewhere on the screen
which you cannot
predict and it is impossible as far as
quantum physics
is concerned you send one photon through
it goes through these two slits it will
appear on the screen at a point which
cannot be predicted what can
pre-predicted is
statistics of what will happen and when
you send many many particles through
the particles which make up life make up
light when
you have enough of them they combine and
form what looks like a wave pattern
but the individual particles coming
through
end up on a screen at a place that
cannot
in principle be detected this applies
to waves and particles and the waves it
might be light but it might be also
electrons and one of the discoveries
foundational discovery of quantum
mechanics was that light
behaves as a particle or a wave under
certain circumstances things that we had
previously thought of as particles
like electrons behave either as a
particle wave
also under the right circumstances and
so you get this idea
that particles or waves waves of
particles which way
matter behaves it depends on the context
and so
the discovery of quantum physics is that
all particles behave like
waves under certain conditions and like
particles
under other conditions and this is the
wonderful experiment
by dr tonomiura and it shows the buildup
of the interference pattern of single
electrons on the left hand side there
are 200
top left particles and it looks like
just a random pattern on the screen
that's number b number c you've got 6
000 ones and you're beginning to see
light and dark patterns showing up
number d is 40 000 and you're beginning
now really to start to see it and in e
you're really seeing now
that interference pattern building up
and that's when you've got 140 000
photons
when you've got this set up the
individual photons or the individual
electrons or you can do it with even
heavier particles people have done it
with
fullerenes molecules that are quite
heavy
each individual particle there's no way
to tell where it will end up on the
screen
but the pattern builds up and the
pattern is an absolutely 100
predictable pattern and the pattern that
eventually emerges is the classical
interference pattern
which we started off with and that is
the basic feature of quantum uncertainty
it's not possible it's not just that we
don't have enough
evidence people have tried to find out
have we been missing
some variable which will determine where
it ends up and they have failed
to find any such variable now there's a
similar thing that happens with an
excited atom if you excite an atom by
heating it up it's
was in a ground state it goes to an
excited state it then sits in that
excited state and eventually it emits
radiation it might be a visible light it
might be
x-ray depending on the frequencies
involved
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas